TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Running TensorFlow across
hundreds of machines
can shorten the training
process for some models
from weeks to hours
and lets us experiment
with models of increasing
size and sophistication.
This distributed
training support
has been one of the most
requested features ever
since we released TensorFlow
as an open source project.
And now it's available
in the latest release.
For more information and
to get started today,
head on over to the blog post.
You're now able to configure
all Cloud Load Balancing flavors
through a unified interface.
While the technologies [? and ?]
the power of the Google Cloud
Platform are complex, the UI
for using the resources on GCP
should be simple and intuitive.
This new UI aims to simplify
Cloud Load Balancing
configuration.
For an overview of the new
UI, check out the post.
Vulkan is a new 3D
rendering API which
we've helped to develop
as a member of Khronos.
It's geared at providing
explicit low-overhead GPU
control to developers.
Vulkan's reduction
of CPU overhead
allows some synthetic
benchmarks to see as much as 10
times the draw call
throughput on a single core
as compared to open GLES.
Combine that with a
threading-friendly API design,
which allows multiple cores
to be used in parallel
with high efficiency.
And today we're pleased to
bring you a preview of Android
development tools for Vulkan.
Jump to the post for
a list of features,
links to samples and guides, and
a video with a tornado of fish.
If you've been wanting
easy-to-follow screencasts
on how to implement the mobile
ads SDK on Android and iOS,
you're in luck.
There's a new video series
called the "Mobile Ads Garage."
Take a peek at the
first episode to learn
how to import the SDK
into your project.
Today, the second
release in our series
of developer previews for
Android N is ready for you
to test against your apps.
You've helped us find
and fix a bunch of bugs
in the first release, and we're
still on the hunt for more.
Head over to the post for some
release notes and instructions
on how to get the update.
OK, a fun thing at the end
here-- three graduate students
at San Francisco
State University
have created a new app for
Project Tango using the Unity
SDK.
It's called Solar Simulator, and
it lets you take a virtual walk
through space to
understand the size
and scale of our solar system.
Want to try it out?
Just head over to
the post for a link
to download the app on your
Project Tango developer kit,
or follow the instructions
to create your own.
Enjoy these updates.
Maybe your friends will too.
Please like, subscribe, and
share, and don't forget,
the links are in the
description below.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]